I in David wine stain I'm with the
National Endowment for the Humanities
I'm the Division of Public Programs and
I'm a program officer there i've been
there about seven years but i'm going to
use a few minutes to give you an
overview of who we are and what we're
doing in terms of funding digital and
what sort of new and exciting at neh
these days thanks very much to the
center and also to Frank Peter and
Maurice for having me and thanks to all
of you one of the reasons that I like to
come to a meeting like this is to worry
about what's going I have just seen lots
of great stuff and and thank you as
Richard suggested in the last session we
really are actively trying to figure out
what's going on in digital humanities
and where should our money go how can we
help you produce the best quality
humanities projects how can we help you
distribute them have when we help you
archive them how do we use new
technology tools to educate the public
and when I say educate I mean broadly
both in and out of school in history
literature philosophy the study of art
and the study of culture sort of what
can we do to make your job easier the
NHS some of you may know is a federal
government agency and our annual budget
is about three billion Doug no it's
about 141 million dollars I wish it were
three billion of other agencies get that
much we get about 141 million dollars
which I used to think sounded like a lot
but the more I see how much some of you
may be working on projects that cost
more than 140 1 million dollars but we
do our best to stretch our money and to
make our money go as far as it can
especially in conjunction with other
funders partnerships etc and I think
you'll be hearing more about that a
little bit later one of the things that
we've rolled out that last year is the
digital humanities initiative now neh is
some funding digital projects for a long
time but we're really focusing on that
now and really trying to figure out how
do we can help you opposition yourselves
in the coming digital world
technologies are converging and how do
we best use technology to serve the
public there's a website the URL is up
there that's devoted to the digital
humanities initiative and one of the
first things that I'd like to suggest
you do if you're at all interested in
this is there's a link join the DHI
update listserv to the left I'm not used
to doing this with the computers in this
net but it's all the way to the left
that link we have a newsletter it tells
you what's going on in terms of funding
what some of the initiatives are and
again you might want to subscribe to
that we're also we've also started to
hold a series of meetings at the neh
with people who are doing interesting
digital work and it wouldn't surprise me
if one day a government agent not done
one of your doors or all of your doors
and asked you to come to Washington or
at least you got an email or something
asking you to come to Washington we've
had two such meetings one focused on
digital humanities centers and the other
I brought some scholars and who were
doing interesting work in digital
humanities and these were pretty
informal discussions again to try to get
a sense of the state of the field and
again program officers do that my main
responsibilities in the Division of
Public Programs i'll talk about that
division in a minute but i do a lot with
documentary film and i have for the last
several years i'm also on a subcommittee
that's doing a lot of the research for
the digital humanities initiative and
it's a digital humanities initiative
that has been doing the research
bringing people over I one of the first
exclusively digital humanities projects
that we have there are the startup
grants would you can find a little
bit about them on the website and we
deliberately use the term start-up grant
to evoke a startup company a YouTube
Google now these are 30,000 Olive Branch
their modest France but the deliverables
by neh standards are also pretty modest
the focus is on technology as much as it
is the humanities and we want really
great ideas and I've heard a lot of them
even at this conference if you have a
way to adapt something you see in the
commercial world to something that could
educate people in the humanities go for
a start-up we're not asking you to build
a mass
civ website portal whatever we're asking
you to start doing that to see if
something is feasible which again is a
little bit unusual at least for any HM
for a lot of funders we're funding ideas
and feasibility and seed money to move a
project forward for innovative ideas we
just made the first set of awards under
the DHI startup grants and it really
ranged across the types of things that
neh does there was some funding for
digitization of archives podcasting 3d
reconstructions of ancient Greek
monuments gaming ways of making
archiving making something open source
even some of the again some of the ideas
that I've met a bit could be an example
of something that's out there wow it
would be great if we could do X and
we're hoping to have at some point
finish up grants it's probably not going
to be called that but something down the
road if we're putting the seed money in
now we'd love to be able to come in down
the road and give you more money to
actually make something happen to
actually follow up on the idea from the
start up grant we also have a
partnership with our colleagues at IMLS
called advancing knowledge and this is
also brand new so I don't have any
examples of what we're going to fund but
we hope to partner with IMLS the fund
innovative collaborations among
libraries museums archives universities
in doing digital projects and again the
awards will probably be announced month
are we in may possibly late July I would
think for that you can get back to me on
that we only have a few times you only
make grants in July is the next time but
if you're at all interested if you're
working in an archive or a museum that's
something you might want to consider and
I'm not positive if we're going to have
that again in the future but there's a
very good possibility that we will in
addition the neh works according to
divisions we have several divisions and
the divisions is sort of organized as
far as the end product and the field
that you're working in if you're doing
something for primarily an education
audience you could apply to the
education division public audiences go
to public programs preservation and
access if you're preserving and making
that material accessible would go to
that division archives generally
libraries generally not exclusively we
have a research division that fun
scholarly projects ciao excuse me
challenge grants for big institutional
grants so within those divisions were
all rolling out programs and we're also
thinking about ways to collaborating
because especially in the digital world
the walls between say an education
project and a public programs are
collapsing we funded a project called
the time warp trio where we funded the
curriculum out of the education division
the TV program for kids added the public
programs and we're looking at ways of
making it easier for applicants this
sort of one-stop shop if that's a verb
come to the neh felt one application and
kind of get all of that funded in a
bigger project and with any bureaucracy
it's hard to bring walls down a little
bit but that's what we're trying to do
but I'd like to run through each
division really quickly and give you a
sense of what's new and exciting in
terms of the digital world and then
afterwards that you happy to take
questions for the end of the panel the
research division funds collaborative
research projects and scholarly projects
some things that they fund that include
databases where especially social
historians will use databases use
computer software to sort data do
research based on that scholarly
publications that might be online
scholarly editions George Washington's
papers jamas Jefferson's papers
annotated online they have a new program
called digital humanities fellowships
which are intended again very broadly to
support scholars who did doing digital
work and it's broad because we want to
see what we get well put the money out
there and we want to see what happens
and this is the first round for the
digital humanities fellowships so I
don't have any examples of what we fund
under that because we haven't funded
anything yet are the education division
I've had some of you receive any agents
or applied of just trying to get a sense
okay some of our good number you
familiar with any ages so I have okay
sorry I'll do what I can later neck um
the education division might be an
interest a lot of you they have teaching
and learning resource grads to develop
curricula including online curricula
digital curricula primary materials for
instructors study guides there's a
website that's hosted by neh called
excitement that has lots of good
resources for instructors it's sort of a
guide to other websites and the
education division is doing something
that you could apply for called digital
humanities workshops whether they want
to train educators and how to best use
digital technology in the classroom now
you might want to call them we get sort
of specialized I'm in public programs
not education so I'm not sure exactly
how that works you may be able to apply
to conduct a workshop you may be able to
apply to participate in the workshop
that's how they usually work so if
you're at all interested in in doing
that you might want to contact a vision
of Education preservation and access
does a lot with scholarly tools for
archiving figuring out best practices
for digital online encyclopedias
digitization projects some of what we've
been talking about today the particular
grant programs that you might want to
look at are the research and development
grants and the reference materials
grants and some of this is sort of on
the left margin just so you know and if
if I'm sifting through this too quickly
just grab me afterwards one of them were
prominent projects at a preservation and
access is the National digital newspaper
program and dnp which were doing in
cooperation with Library of Congress and
it's a massive project
try to digitize and make searchable all
of America's newspapers historically and
I think that they just unrolled either a
beta version or the actual version of we
also have a division of challenge grants
which again supports institutional
projects there's a new program their
national humanities challenge grants to
help humanity centers get going and my
division is the Division of Public
Programs we support museum exhibitions
including online exhibitions we support
television projects we supported a
couple that were discussed over this
conference we shall remain which mark
your drains from WGBH talked about
yesterday Native American history the
detroit michigan state / detroit
projects or his black journal we put
some money into that making those
programs online and a variety a lot of
times when there's a companion website
to a TV program we put money into that
sometimes this is standalone digital
projects sometimes in conjunction with
the funding of the TV program we also
support stand-alone digital projects
that are intended for public audiences
through the division of public forums we
have different levels of funding
development funding which could be
thirty thousand sixty thousand dollars
up to what we call implementation or
production funding which could be up to
eight hundred thousand dollars so that's
the sort of quick and dirty this website
also has examples of projects that we
have funded towards the bottom and there
are lots more for each division so you
can see there are any age funded
projects and you welcome all for this
link to check those out to give you a
sense of what we're looking for and let
me give you my email address in my phone
number in case you have any questions
about all any or all of this again the
name david weinstein my email is d
weinstein my first initial and last name
at any age govt and my direct line is 20
to 60 68 308 why do I give you my direct
line because i like talking to people we
have a beautiful office
this wonderful historic building if
anybody has ever been that the 19th
century old post office building and we
have the most drab cubicles in the world
so I like outside contact but please
call me thank you